Imagina que estás resolviendo un sistema
de dos ecuaciones lineales con dos incógnitas,
y has encontrado más de una solución que
satisfaga el sistema.
¿Cuál de las siguientes afirmaciones es verdad?
Y bueno, antes de leer estas afirmaciones,
que por cierto, están bien entretenidas.
lo que quiero ver es de una forma gráfica,
¿qué está pasando con este problema?
Así que déjame dibujarte aquí mis dos ejes,
este va a ser mi eje de las "y",
este de aquí va a ser mi eje de las "x" y bueno,
si estamos hablando
acerca de dos ecuaciones lineales,
de una manera gráfica
estamos hablando de dos rectas,  por lo tanto
podemos estar en 3 posibles escenarios.
Que estas dos rectas nunca se intersecten,
es decir, voy a dibujar aquí dos rectas paralelas,
que cada una de estas ecuaciones lineales
me represente una recta
y estas rectas nunca se intersecten,
como este caso de aquí.
Ahora bien, en este caso de aquí no tenemos
solución porque estas dos rectas no se intersectan
y date cuenta que en este problema,
no podemos estar en este caso porque nos dicen
que hemos encontrado más de una solución.
Entonces este caso no es y entonces vamos
a fijarnos en nuestro segundo caso.
Nuestro segundo caso es que tuviéramos dos
rectas que se intersectaran en un solo punto,
este punto sería la solución de mi sistema,
ahora date cuenta que las líneas
son un poco rígidas
y por lo tanto solamente se intersectan aquí,
en este punto
y como solamente tenemos una intersección,
mi solución es única
y por lo tanto
tampoco podría ser ésta nuestra respuesta,
porque el problema nos dice que
hemos encontrado más de una solución,
así que nuestro tercer caso es que
tuviéramos la misma recta,
que mis dos rectas fueran la misma recta, en cuyo caso, cada uno de los puntos sería solución de este sistema,
no solamente tendríamos dos soluciones,
tendríamos una infinidad de soluciones
porque estas dos rectas se intersectan
en cada uno de sus puntos.
Y entonces como el problema nos dice que hemos
encontrado más de una solución,
quiere decir que estamos en este caso,
que por cierto, date cuenta que es el inciso c.
Existe una infinidad más
de soluciones del sistema.
Justo este inciso.